♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est un peu tôt,
mais ça s'en vient :
avec cette année, une pénurie
appréhendée de jouets.
KARINE FOISY, présidente,
boutique Veille sur toi
- Si vous voyez le jouet
convoité pour votre enfant
sur les tablettes, n'hésitez pas
parce que c'est pas certain
qu'il va être encore là
en décembre ou même en novembre.
- En raison des retards
dans le transport maritime,
surtout en provenance d'Asie,
les biens de consommation,
entre autres les jouets,
se font rares. La pandémie
a complètement chamboulé
le transport maritime,
qui représente 80 % du transit
de marchandises dans le monde.
JACQUES ROY, prof. gestion
transport et logistique, HEC
- La chaîne d'approvisionnement
mondiale est bouleversée depuis
le tout début de la pandémie.
On se retrouve donc avec une
pénurie de conteneurs vides,
une demande qui augmente
et des problèmes aussi
de fabrication, des usines
en Chine qui doivent
être fermées également
à cause de la pandémie.
- La forte demande
pour une panoplie de produits
se stabilisera un jour,
mais cette année, eh bien,
c'est un peu tard.
- C'est clair que cet automne,
avec la forte demande pour
les produits de consommation,
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'espoir
en vue.
- J'essaie de compléter
mes achats de Noël. Je sais que
cette année, il faut s'y prendre
un petit plus tôt.
- J'aime ça me prendre en
avance, là, t'sais, parce que
c'est tellement difficile
de trouver des jouets
ces temps-ci.
- Nos commandes sont passées
depuis longtemps, mais sont
arrivées au compte-goutte.
- Karine Foisy, de la boutique
"Veille sur toi", à Laval, est
aussi distributrice de jouets
auprès de 300 détaillants
au Canada. Elle achète et vend
maintenant beaucoup de jouets
fabriqués au Québec.
- Consommer local aussi,
c'est une façon de remédier
à ce problème-là. On a beaucoup
de compagnies ici qui font
de merveilleux jouets.
- (Père-Noël): Joyeux Noël!
Ho, ho, ho!
- Un Père-Noël peut-être
moins généreux cette année.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
- Joyeux Noël, tout le monde!
Ho, ho